[Music]  here comes another eco-friendly manner  to recycle tires Egypt produces twenty  million tonnes of tire waste per year of  which only ten percent is recycled  properly often useless tires are burned  but that releases toxic pollutants into  the air engineering students in Cairo  recently built a rubber recycling  machine that turns tires into  alternative fuel the shredded tires are  heated in the machine until they reach  evaporation point the vapor then  dissipates into a condenser the  remaining carbon or black coal residue  can then be used to produce new tires or  stadium floors get the real beneficial  product is diesel oil the students say  it's very similar to pure diesel and  this can be used to drive machines in  cement or brick factories do you like  that  if you are also doing your bit tell us  about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bit we share your  stories  [Applause]